[Música]
definida en la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales en ecuador
tras 14 días de incertidumbre el consejo
nacional electoral proclamó esta
madrugada que el corréis andrew zarautz
quien ganó en la primera vuelta con 32
puntos 72% de los votos se enfrentará al
conservador guillermo lasso quien obtuvo
el 19 punto 74 por ciento de los
sufragios
en españa' por quinta noche consecutiva
las manifestaciones por la detención del
rapero pablo hasél señalado de incitar
al terrorismo en curar a la corona se
tomaron varias ciudades del país en
barcelona el tono de las protestas subió
cuando algunos manifestantes se
enfrentaron con la policía y destrozaron
varios comercios
miles de personas volvieron a salir este
domingo a las calles de la ciudad de
mandalay en mianmar donde ayer murieron
dos manifestantes por disparos de la
policía durante una protesta contra la
junta militar que tomó el poder mediante
un golpe de estado mientras tanto
facebook eliminó la página principal del
ejército alegando incitación a la
violencia
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 sierra blanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en el ecuador donde la madrugada de este
domingo se conocieron los resultados
oficiales de la primera vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales del pasado 7
de febrero luego de varias audiencias
fallidas y un largo debate de 14 días
para recontar todas las actas el
candidato andrés hará uso del respaldado
por el ex presidente rafael correa
consiguió el 32 puntos 72 por ciento y
el centroderechista guillermo lasso
obtuvo el 19 puntos 74 por ciento de los
votos según los resultados oficiales del
consejo nacional electoral los
candidatos se enfrentarán en la segunda
vuelta el próximo 11 de abril el
candidato ya cooper es en tercer puesto
de nuncio supuesto fraude en su contra
mientras que la contraloría buscaría
auditar el sistema electrónico electoral
la presidenta del consejo nacional
electoral de ese país habló esta
madrugada
se colocan los resultados definitivos de
la votación para la dignidad de
presidente y vicepresidente de la
república señor secretarios se dispone
desde que desde la secretaría general la
elaboración de la respectiva resolución
de programación de los resultados
definitivos las mismas que deberá ser
notificada a las organizaciones
políticas para press para aquellas ellas
podrán presentar los recursos
administrativos o jurisdiccionales de
los cuales se crean asistidos y es que
más temprano nuestro corresponsal
gustavo ortega de séquito nos amplió
esta información y les explica sobre el
peritaje al sistema informático
electoral que se llevará a cabo hoy
a 14 días de las elecciones
presidenciales el consejo nacional
electoral proclamó los resultados
oficiales
andrés arados y guillermo lasso se
disputarán en segunda vuelta electoral
el 11 de abril ya q pérez quedaría en
tercer lugar en los comicios
presidenciales nos fueron aceptadas sus
solicitudes de abrir las urnas en 100%
en guayas y 50% en 16 provincias del
país sólo se aceptó un reconteo parcial
en 26 actas en dos provincias del país
la proclamación se produce en medio de
tensiones entre el órgano comicial la
contraloría y la fiscalía general del
estado que han aprobado para este
domingo un peritaje del sistema
informático electoral
la diligencia se producirá a partir de
las 7 y 30 de la mañana que ha sido
calificada con una falta grave
considerada como una intervención en
medio de un proceso electoral mientras
tanto los principales candidatos lo han
calificado como un intento de evitar la
segunda vuelta electoral y anular así
las elecciones a presidente del ccn se
ha pronunciado ya exhortar a los
principales organismos a no hacerse eco
del juego político para preservar
intereses partidistas saludamos en este
momento a hernán pérez luz abogado
analista político y columnista del
diario 'el universo' abogado gracias por
estar con nosotros en france 24
le pregunto porque el consejo nacional
electoral ecuatoriano tardó 14 días en
dar un resultado final y poder conocer
al candidato que se enfrentará en la
segunda vuelta con antes araus buenos
días y gracias por la invitación
efectivamente no hay una explicación
convincente de esa demora
lamentablemente durante el conteo de la
noche de las elecciones
hubo una enorme cantidad de actas que de
alguna manera se les llama actas con
novedades en la que la ley permite o más
bien obliga a que se las vuelva a
recontar aparte podrá encontrar ciertas
inconsistencias errores o sospechas de
algún tipo de d
[Música]
errores básicamente y esas actas se
demoraron en ser recontadas debieron
haberla hecho rápidamente porque el país
quedó en se presentó una una polémica
una polémica política de alto tono entre
los dos candidatos que se disputaban
entrada a la segunda vuelta y con el
pedido de uno de ellos del señor ya q
pérez de que prácticamente se recorte en
todas las actas de todo todas de todo el
país el problema es que la ley no
permite eso hacerlo sería prácticamente
que no tener una segunda vuelta sino
hasta después de varios meses si usted
abre la urna de todo el país y vuelve a
contar la votación obviamente hubo un
acuerdo político entre los candidatos
más bien limitando el reconteo de las
actas en ciertas provincias y
aparentemente eso tampoco tiene un
asidero en la en la ley se y el consejo
lo que ha hecho es básicamente proceder
a hacer el anuncio
la segunda vuelta y abrir la posibilidad
ahora sí de iniciar las impugnaciones
gracián del caso abogado general yo esa
disputa entre el candidato ya q pérez y
guillermo lazo el candidato pérez quedó
entonces en el tercer lugar según dijo
el consejo nacional electoral pero
también el denuncia como se también lo
decía que hubo irregularidades incluso
fraude electoral en esta primera vuelta
de las elecciones del pasado 7 de
febrero le pregunto en qué se basan las
denuncias de pérez y quema novia en qué
maniobra tiene para poder apelar estos
resultados bueno mire
lamentablemente el candidato pérez no ha
presentado realmente impugnaciones de
acuerdo con la ley y digamos
específicamente y yo soy indicios muy
claros
lamentablemente digo porque esto crea
pues obviamente una atmósfera de dudas
simplemente decir que cree que porque no
ha entrado la segunda vuelta 'ipso
facto' se ha cometido un fraude
electoral básicamente parte del problema
radica que la noche de las elecciones la
presidenta del consejo nacional
electoral incurrió en un lamentable
error al dar por un hecho ya que el
señor pérez estaba segundo en las
elecciones cuando aún no terminaba del
conteo oficial
ese tipo de anuncios no se hace como
usted sabe cuando a las márgenes de
aproximación entre dos candidaturas es
muy es muy estrecho y ese es lo que
estamos pasando ahora la consecuencia de
haber haberse precipitado a dar porque
han hecho ya que el señor pérez era el
segundo ahora abogado que podemos
esperar en la segunda vuelta del 11 de
abril estaríamos frente al triunfo del
correo y está andrés araujo guillermo
lazo tiene chance de finalmente quedarse
con la presidencia del país en sus en su
tercer intento
es muy difícil predecir esto hace cuatro
años el señor lazo quedó segundo en la
primera vuelta algo parecido a lo que
está hoy en día y tenía en su contra en
la segunda vuelta electoral a todo el
gobierno del presidente correa
a la fuerza que hoy apoya el señor pérez
también apoyándolo al señor lenin moreno
y a pesar de eso prácticamente quedó
empatada a la elección para algunos hubo
un triunfo de lazo o recordará quizá
usted el apagón electrónico que sufrió
el ecuador por varias horas el día de la
segunda vuelta electoral así que no está
todo dicho
es un margen considerable pero no es
tampoco un margen irremontable abogado
un gusto haber conversado con usted
sobre lo que ocurre en ecuador en torno
a estas elecciones presidenciales que
tengo usted un feliz resto de día y
feliz domingo nosotros continuamos con
más información 34 personas fueron
detenidas el sábado tras otra noche de
violentas protestas en cataluña por el
encarcelamiento del rapero pablo hasél
quien fue condenado a nueve meses de
prisión por la publicación de una serie
de tuits considerados como
enaltecimiento al terrorismo e insultos
a la corona los disturbios se han
replicado en otras ciudades españolas
como madrid tarragona pamplona y granada
los manifestantes se enfrentaron con la
policía antidisturbios durante la quinta
noche de protestas en barcelona las
autoridades dispararon gases
lacrimógenos en un intento de dispersar
a la multitud entre los manifestantes de
estos avant ventana saqueaban tiendas e
incendiaban contenedores y motocicletas
la ira inundó las calles por el arresto
del rapero pablo hasél que está en el
centro de una controversia sobre la
libertad de expresión
hazel fue detenido por la policía el
martes luego de un enfrentamiento de 24
horas en un edificio universitario el
hombre de 32 años cumple una condena de
nueve meses de prisión por insultar a la
monarquía española y elogiar el
terrorismo en varias ciudades se han
llevado a cabo protestas
mayoritariamente pacíficas pidiendo su
liberación durante el sábado los
residentes expresaron su frustración por
el daño causado por los disturbios
no puede ser estado destruido todo
quemado o el plástico todas las noches
helicópteros estamos un poquito hartos
la verdad yo no violencia no estoy de
acuerdo cuando rompen negación estragos
eso ya no tiene ninguna justificación el
caso ha provocado un debate nacional
sobre la libertad de expresión en medio
de llamadas a un cambio en la denominada
ley mordaza del país el gobierno español
ha anunciado que eliminará las penas de
prisión por delitos relacionados con la
libertad de expresión pero las enmiendas
propuestas no afectarán la sentencia del
rapero
las manifestaciones en mianmar no paran
tras 21 días del golpe militar tres
personas han muerto en medio de la
violenta represión por parte de los
militares y las fuerzas de seguridad de
una de ellas una joven de 20 años que se
ha convertido en un símbolo de la
resistencia a las huelgas siguen
pidiendo la abolición de la constitución
que es muy favorable al ejército el
regreso del gobierno civil y la
liberación de los detenidos incluida la
respuesta líder a un samsung
[Música]
entre la ira y el duelo los
manifestantes no se desmovilizan aún son
miles de personas que alzan la voz
contra los militares en el poder tras el
golpe de estado del pasado primero de
febrero las últimas víctimas fatales son
dos personas que murieron en mandalay
incluido un menor que recibió un disparo
en la cabeza
somos manifestantes pacifistas detengan
el genocidio dejen de usar armas letales
queremos que la comunidad internacional
adopte medidas más duras y no solo las
sanciones otras 30 personas resultaron
heridas según los rescatistas y médicos
la mitad de las víctimas fueron atacadas
con munición real la escalada de
tensiones provocó nuevas condenas
internacionales condenó el uso de la
violencia mortal en mianmar el uso de
fuerza letal la intimidación y el acoso
contra manifestantes pacíficos es
inaceptable todos tienen derecho a
reunirse pacíficamente hago un llamado a
todas las partes para que respeten los
resultados de las elecciones y vuelvan a
un gobierno civil ni al mar está privado
de internet desde hace una semana
facebook por su parte bloqueó la cuenta
del ejército por incitar a la violencia
este domingo tuvo lugar el funeral de la
primera víctima una joven que murió por
heridas de bala y que se ha convertido
en todo un símbolo de la resistencia
anti junta militar
israel da un paso más hacia su des
escalada con la reapertura de gran parte
de los negocios se inicia el uso del
certificado verde también se permite la
apertura de gimnasios piscinas hoteles y
espacios para eventos deportivos o
culturales como teatros pero solo se
autoriza la entrada a los ciudadanos que
hayan recibido las dos dosis de la
vacuna o que hayan superado este virus
este domingo los ciudadanos de la
república de níger en áfrica occidental
uno de los países más pobres del mundo
acuden a las urnas en la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales entre
el candidato oficialista a mohamed
bazoum y el expresidente mahaman usman
según las estadísticas de la comisión
electoral un total de 7.4 millones de
votantes están llamados a participar en
estos comicios nuestro corresponsal en
burkina faso el cálido su xiv viajó
hasta la capital de níger niamey y desde
allí nos cuenta cómo estuvo la apertura
de los colegios y que está en juego en
esta contienda electoral como puedo ver
hay una larga cola en la mesa de
votación de una escuela de miami donde
estoy hay que decir que esta mañana se
ha rechazó la puerta de los colegios
electorales cuando deben haber abierto a
las 8 de la mañana en que en cada mesa
de votación tenemos un rock descendente
de la comisión electoral nacional
independiente asistido por los delegados
de cada candidato en primer lugar lo que
está en juego en esta votación es
institucional
recordemos que el presidente mamadú
issoufou no se representa a sí mismo al
final de estos dos mandatos y por lo
tanto por primera vez desde su
independencia ni se experimentará una
transferencia pacífica de poder entre
dos presidentes electos la pregunta es
si los candidatos aceptarán los
resultados de la encuentras tú también y
sobre todo tienes esta pregunta de
seguridad inicial es atacado por votar
en el este del país y los de calidad y
el estado está mejor en el oeste del
país todas estas preguntas no deben
ocultar las dificultades de desarrollo
de iniciar el país ha estado ha estado
en el último lugar en el índice de
desarrollo humano de la onu durante
nueve años es uno de los países más
pobres del mundo que sin embargo produce
petróleo
cálidos y nuestro enviado especial a
níger hasta aquí el informativo france24
continúa con nosotros mandía
[Música]
france24 en español